a second coronavirus vaccine could be
approved as soon as tomorrow
after an fda advisory panel meets today
and that's a good news moment at an
especially
dire time daily cases hit nearly a
quarter million yesterday
that is an all-time high more than 3600
deaths were reported at the same time
that is also a record
our lead national correspondent david
begneau is at a hospital in fresno
california david good morning
to you word is there it's a desperate
situation where you are
yeah look we were told we're sick and
tired of getting sick and being tired
that's what they said to us when we
called this hospital the largest
hospital
in the central valley here in california
we started the week in northern
california made the drive south stopped
here to check on them
and we found tents outside they told us
there are no icu beds available
they have 450 employees who are out half
of them are sick with cove but the other
half were exposed to covet
they have more employees out than they
have coveted patients in the hospital
and they're so busy with those patients
busting it seams
in california hospitals are doing
everything they can to keep up
whether that means setting up beds in
the hospital's conference room
or tents in the parking lot outside our
bed capacity is zero
doctor race bora is an emergency room
doctor here at community regional
medical center in fresno
we see influenza we see pneumonia really
everything is coming in at the same time
in addition to this surge in kovid and
we're just running out of space
but more help could be on the way very
soon in the form of another coronavirus
vaccine
this time from moderna today it goes
before the fda's independent advisory
committee on vaccines
dr arnold monto is the acting chair of
that group i think the discussion
may be a little simpler because they are
not
asking for authorization in the 16 to 17
year olds
so if approved moderna would be
available to people of what age groups
18 and above as modernist vaccine gets
closer to approval
doses of the pfizer vaccine are now
arriving at nursing homes across the
country
and over the last 72 hours tens of
thousands of doses
have made it into the arms of doctors
nurses and seniors nationwide
but on wednesday officials in alaska
reported the first known instances of an
adverse allergic reaction to the vaccine
here in the u.s
it happened to two health care workers
in juneau within 10 minutes of each
other
one fully recovered while the other
remained in the hospital for observation
she was still enthusiastic that she got
the vaccine
and then there are the stories of
survival like natalie herrera
the 35 year old was hospitalized in
southern california with coronavirus at
37 weeks pregnant
now to save her life doctors performed
an emergency c-section
and delivered her son felipe but natalie
got sicker
she spent a month in the hospital
critically ill
unable to see her son but on tuesday she
got to go home
and meet that baby boy what is the first
thing you did when you saw him
i smelled him i smelled
i smelled his little head here
how sweet it is i want to go back and
talk about those allergic reactions
listen
experts say those are extremely rare but
if you are prone
to usually having a reaction with a
vaccine you should not get this vaccine
unless you talk to your doctor and you
guys agree that it's right
for you as for the moderna vaccine
listen it doesn't require those
ultra cold freezers that pfizer does so
moderna could be more widespread maybe
even arguable
arguably more popular because for the
smaller nursing homes
doctor's offices in rural america they
can put the modern vaccine in the common
freezer like you and i have
at home gail yeah that is good news i'm
still
stuck on the lady who smelled the baby's
hair i love that part of the story thank
you very much david sweet right
it is it is i love that kind of moment
we need those thanks